hi everyone uh hugo bound anderson here
um i work in data science and evangelism
and developer relations and all these
types of uh fun things um and i'm
excited to get spooky on halloween today
with you uh talking about dusk for
everyone uh and a lot of the things a
lot of people are thinking about these
days but in particular
a story from a company called called
coiled which is uh incredibly close
close to my heart but this is a general
pattern we're seeing in the space
at the moment as well and i want to make
that clear so the tldr if you want to
leave after a minute or two um is that
dark makes distributed computing
particularly with the pi data stack but
distributed computing more generally
easy
then when you want to do stuff at scale
or productionized stuff it adds lots of
additional challenges
what happens then um a lot of people are
building interesting products such as
coiled to try to make this uh easy again
so um on dust making distributed
computer easy i'm going to skip this
i'll say a few words but there are many
talks at this conference about dusk
so definitely check check all of them
out
um we're going to focus on the
additional challenges uh with a specific
example and the types of products and
coiled that we're we're talking about
the punchline is you can pip and store
coil it comes as a pip installable
package you can import coiled and then
get your cluster spun up on aws gcp
azure or on-prem uh in a matter of
minutes you'll be hard-pressed to make a
cup of coffee in the time unless some
maybe you've got an aeropress on your
desk
so what i'd like to do is start with uh
an example of um
scaling uh pandas and machine learning
workflow okay so you've got some tabular
data in a pandas data frame you're using
xg boost because i don't know you love
kaggle competitions uh no that's um all
jokes aside um because actually boost is
cool and fast okay so this is what this
slide is incredible okay
i don't actually mean you know we made a
beautiful slide for you all to watch
what i mean by that is the fact that in
you know five lines of code
you can you can get a model up and
running and and training on uh a data
set so let's just have a look at what's
happened here with conda installed
xgboost and pandas um then we have
wgetted uh
uh dataset so it's the heat's boson
dataset um and it's a small version of
it um because we're gonna work it
initially work on it initially locally
with pandas and xgboost then we import
our libraries then we read in the data
frame uh the csv into a data frame and
then we train our model uh on the data
frame okay now
you know in the past 10 years of course
we've seen a lot of incredible uh
apis developed in the pi data ecosystem
and this speaks uh a huge amount um to
the kind of the rapid adoption and the
hockey stick growth we've seen in the
python space in in particular
okay so this is how you would do
panderson xg boost on a laptop right um
but most laptops have several cores
these days so if you want to do some
parallelization
uh or in your hyperparameter sweep or
something along those lines um
i'm sorry i just wanted to make clear i
did say this in in passing but what i've
just done and showed you works really
well uh and it's fully accessible to
anyone with a laptop and some time to
learn you need to check out some api
docs get some software installed and
then you're up and running okay so as i
was saying if you want to um
you know leverage all the cores on your
laptop you can think about um doing that
in a relatively straightforward way
which we'll see now uh using das okay so
this is pandas and xgboost and using
some form of distributed compute on your
local machine uh in order to speed speed
things up okay so we can under install
all our things again
actually this looks really similar to
the code before and i'll point out the
the only differences uh we're importing
dark data frame as dd instead of pandas
as pd and we've
changed uh pd.read csv to dd dot read
csv um this is beautiful i'm one of the
many reasons i love darsk uh is that not
only does it mimic the pandas api or the
numpy api or the psychic learn api
depending on what what you're trying to
do what you want to be doing but under
the hood for the most part it uh runs
the code you think it's running um and
what that means is that your mental
model of what's happening in the back
end is actually what's happening so for
example you don't battle with javascript
errors uh
um when i'm sorry java error is when
importing um a data set
so what i've just showed you will work
well
and fully accessible today with anyone
with a laptop and a bit of time to learn
and maybe a bit more time to learn you
need to install das and get a few things
uh up and running there but
you know if you have a bit more time to
learn you can you can do all of that
okay
so
what if you want to be leveraging uh a
cluster using uh distributed computation
that's not on your laptop okay so then
you'll be using as we've just seen
pandas and xg boost and dash but not on
a laptop uh on a cluster so let's say
for example
i don't know you're at work and you find
out you have a kubernetes cluster that
that you can access okay so
what do you do then um
hopefully it would be
somewhat straightforward as the previous
example so we could try condor
installing this stuff then importing our
packages
namespaces and then bringing in our data
notice that this is the large data set
now okay uh the higgs large the large
higgs boson data set um so we're going
to really try to leverage the
distributed compute of our
kubernetes cluster there and then we
train train the model so fingers crossed
whoa
um
fingers crossed it works and as as we'll
see there are lots of many moving parts
that go
go into this and so this is what the
next part of the story is going to be
about how we get that code up and
running um and the truth is
this works well as i write here and it
is fully accessible today to anyone with
a whole variety of different skills and
and pieces of knowledge that we're going
to try to put put together okay
so how do we set this up um so i'm going
to tell you something we've seen
um
in in terms of kind of the general
patterns that we see people trying to
figure this out how to get um
the cluster up and running um or desk an
xg boost and pandas for example up and
running on a cluster
so you may google dusk on the cloud and
there you go the dart stocks the dust
stocks are pretty good okay so we see
there's a page on cloud deployments
and i see there's a managed kubernetes
service
there are a few other things um
so
let's say i'm going to go and create an
aws account and i
need to you know do some things and you
know maybe
if it's my work stuff i need to get like
some secrets a key and a token or
something along those lines
um and then i'm in there and it's like
oh how many clusters do i want how many
node pools that type of stuff so i'm
trying to get my kubernetes cluster
trying to get and get a piece with that
um
and then all right no i've got a
uh i've got linux locally so i've got to
install cube cover okay so i do that
that sounds good
um so now we're back here and hopefully
um with all this stuff and i probably
need to put a bit more in information in
here
in order to access the cluster
and fingers crossed i can execute this
code now after doing that setup
and i have a module not found error
and that's no module named xgboost and
but
so i've installed xgboost i've imported
it and the import area is from the
remote workers on the cluster right so
on this cluster that i'm trying to
leverage um i have xg boost locally but
i but i don't have it out out there so
what i need to do now is make sure that
my environment my computational
environment
matches
um
locally and up on up on the cluster so
how do i how do i get all
my environment all the stuff i want up
on
up on all my uh workers
on my kubernetes cluster okay um so i do
a bit of research and i realize that
there's something called dark docker
which can allow me to get you know
containers all up and running on all my
all my workers um and you know i do a
bit of command line stuff and and figure
this out on that
that's kind of straightforward but um
okay so having done that then i'm like
okay now i've got
everything up and running there and down
here that should be chill
okay what's happened there i've got an
s3 permission error i cannot read this
yes so the problem there is that my aws
credentials are not on the remote
workers so when they try to access the
data set
they can't so i need to give them uh
permission somehow now as well
so what i'm gonna do uh is
upload my aws
credentials so that every worker can can
see them do not do this and we'll see
why uh later but what if what i just did
is i put secure information uh across
potentially uh
non-secure networks no okay so this type
of stuff is now available to potentially
a lot of people who i don't want to have
access to these things and who i t in
particular
uh may be
relatively if not more so unhappy with
okay
but i've done it um and look it actually
works so essentially uh what i've done
is i've gone from pandas and xgboost
locally to doing it uh quickly uh
leveraging the distributed compute of my
laptop to
use pandas plus xg boost plus dash
locally and then to leverage the power
of the cloud um i've i've done it on a
kubernetes cluster and it's working now
we encountered some issues stuff that
will come up again but having said that
it actually
works which i'm pretty excited by and
look i can see all my cool uh tasks
stream uh and all the all the processing
happen happening and that type of stuff
maybe i've got some little combines
going on here or something something
along those lines so that's um that's
really cool i got it up and running
there
so this does feel really good and now we
do have tools to scale i'll say anything
it's really nearly nearly anything to be
honest and what i mean by that is um
if you check out go and check out
dark.org
and have a look at all the different uh
in interoperable packages and frameworks
so you can uh distribute scikit-learn xg
boost pandas numpy um rapids for all all
of your gpu um desires x-ray uh panchio
all of all of these things um so
if you have scalability uh challenges um
and you're using a variety of pi data
and other types of packages i'd i very
much
encourage you to
to check it out
okay now we see some
that's like mitosis perhaps there was a
mitotic spindle and maybe some
uh motor proteins there
cool thing is you can even try gpus for
a while that's
also difficult for other reasons i'd i'd
uh direct you to check out um
matt rocklin who he was the
um
creator of dusk along with several other
people but he made the first commit uh
and uh ceo of coyle uh among many other
things about check out his talk from
nvidia's gtc about deploying with gpus
this is nice though okay things are good
until
it finds out and this will lead to a
series of pretty embarrassing questions
that many of us may have been
um
involved in previously
so firstly they come to me and they say
you're spending 17k a month um the work
you're doing is fine um i appreciate
that um
because i'm always driving for fine work
uh but they've told me i've left up two
idle clusters
that have been on for a long time and
each of the early ah
so yeah there were load balancers that
remained active and that that's totally
on me and this this happens right
they've also told me that there's an
open insecure uh network connection okay
so
um not only can anyone connect to my
schedulers and run arbitrary python code
but i'm actually sending sensitive
company data on unencrypted connections
okay that's also on me and i when i did
it i actually told you never never do
what i'm doing okay and these are the
lines of code that actually did it and
look with great power comes great
responsibility right because the power
to be able to write two lines of code to
do this type of stuff can create a lot
of a lot of harm as well so let's be um
mindful of that
right and on top of that uh those aws
credentials allow impersonation
um my teammates are operating as me and
anyone can connect in and and pretty
much do anything
but nothing bad happened
having said that
we need to be more careful okay
so this is good though i've demonstrated
proof of principle got out some early
results perhaps some business leaders
were like hey you know this is this is
good stuff can we do more of this
all the teammates people in the
organization want to use uh the same
system that's really cool
i've set it all up so now i'm kind of in
charge which is
a career change um having said that i
just wanted to train an
xg boost model and
i'm a data scientist and now i'm kind of
i've been shoehorned by myself into an
infrastructure um position which not
only involves this all these headaches
have set up i just showed you but um a
large amount of non-trivial maintenance
as well
okay so
what i want to do
is go back in time and try a different
approach okay so we're going to rewind
we're going
we're going back we're going back
through our desk uh setup journey okay
and what i'm going to do instead
is
i'm going to introduce you to
something called coil okay
which is a company and product uh that
dust maintainers
have developed um among other people but
the pattern i just showed you
essentially was one of the res on
detroit's four coiled okay so dust
maintainers saw this pattern the pain
the suffering the headaches the harm
happened time and time again and some of
them made a company to automate it and
that company
is coil and as i said this is a general
pattern as well um maybe i'll say a
couple more words about this what i mean
by that is not only is this i mean this
doesn't only pertain to pandas and
xgboost right um but not only is it a
general pattern for dark but this is a
general pattern for
compute in general whether i was trying
to distribute compute what i was trying
to do scalable compute whether it's
trying to deploy things in in production
deploy models in production for example
um
we don't have good systems yet we're
trying to build them this industry
tool builders are trying to build them
to connect local experimentation with at
scale deployment and large-scale uh
training and uh scalable distributed
compute right so moving from from
notebooks
um to
to the cloud right and it comes in all
varieties
of shapes and packages and i'll just
point out if you notice kind of the what
is now a really mature pi data stack um
nearly every package in the pi data
stack uh is is about initially
leveraging uh local compute in order to
do science it isn't necessarily about uh
doing large scale deployable compute in
in in production dask is though probably
one of the packages in the pi data stack
which is
is on the journey there but it's it's a
it's a story that we're seeing time and
time again now that data scientists need
to figure out how to do distributed
compute and and deploy uh their models
uh among other things okay so this is
kind of you know
the next level of the industry
so to speak so
how does how does coil work um and in
all honesty it is nearly as
straightforward as this you pip install
coil
then you import it as you would anything
else
and then you create your cluster and
this will take
um a minute or or two um so to think
about to kind of reiterate the type of
problems that we need sold and like
coils working towards we need hosted gas
clusters okay so a question we hear a
lot is how do i launch many dark workers
and connect them together um so what
coil does in the background uses the
low-level cloud apis uh to provision
resources as you need them takes a
minute or two and it's available on the
three clouds and on-prem as well okay
huge challenge that we saw of managed
software how do i get all the libraries
i needed installed on my workers and the
approach coil takes um is they solve in
environments on their servers uh excuse
the typo there um
build images and and push them to
container registries and they can also
store solved environments for local use
by you
or others and there's a coiled um crate
software in environment function which
allows you to specify
um
anything from content channels pip or
whatever it is
um
now
in terms of
thinking about the type of ergonomic
tools data scientists need and love in
order to
i suppose do their work at high velocity
and stay in flow states we really
need to think more about
how such frameworks
can interoperate with flexible
development in environments okay so
let's say i use vs code or pycharm or
jupyter notebook jupyter lab how do i
access my clusters through that um and
what coil has done is they've developed
a system where they can proxy
connections from anywhere so uh they
don't force you into their development
environment um
and like darth code is designed for uh
integrating into wherever you
you like to work best okay
um
another problem is that of cost
management so how do i keep costs down
uh coiled will track users usage per
users per team shut down idle clusters
by default uh and scan for idle
resources and i think one thing we're
thinking about the individual data
scientists here but we're actually
thinking about how they're embedded in
an organization as well so who are the
key stakeholders here there are the data
scientists and analysts of course but
then there's it which we've spoken to
then there are team leads who are very
concerned of course
um necessarily so about cost cost
management uh they'll also
uh be concerned about telemetry uh which
we'll get to in a second um
but there's also the challenge for data
scientists of uh executing covered as
quickly as possible um and of course
leveraging uh the capabilities of
uh gpus is important for that um so a
common question that we hear a lot is
how do i leverage advanced hardware and
libraries like rapids pi torch
xg blazing sql uh and and and so on
um and to that encode will provision
gpus for you and includes pre-configured
software environments that you can use
and modify
um
there's a challenge of security which is
which we've already talked about um with
respect to data uh sensitive data and
how we can make sure that no one else
sees it um
so i mean table stakes here is to have
uh end-to-end network security and to
manage resources you can manage it all
inside your cloud account this works
on-prem as well
um
so
as we've said um it's multi-cloud and
on-prem which is uh super exciting if
your data
isn't on on amazon for example um
and
i thought just in the end to wrap up by
talking about how it scales in human
dimensions um and these
this is what we're seeing a lot of now
um we're seeing
what i want to say here i want to say
that the open source stacks
have been very good
at meeting the needs of individual data
scientists analysts and researchers
but when we embed people in
organizations there are all types of
other needs that that arise that we've
already seen in throughout this talk
okay but we still want to meet the needs
of humans working with data um through
computational engines right so we want
to make
the software
and stack and products as human-centric
as possible
and this is why for example um
called make sure that you can drive from
anywhere and use your own development
environment that's why that makes sure
there are pre-configured software
environments um on top of that it's one
of the reasons to make sure that there's
a freemium model uh with credits that
renew uh in
every every month okay
um so to wrap up the scales for human
needs and also to organizational needs
you can deploy into your own
infrastructure you can manage user users
teams quotas track usage gather
telemetry um
and let's enter in security and best
practices uh so
i'd just like to wrap up by thanking um
pi data global for
having me talk here and thanking you all
for for joining i've got no idea what
time zone you're in i'm in sydney
australia and it's 7pm on a friday um
but i really appreciate you all sticking
around and listening and i wish you a
very spooky uh halloween
so maybe we've got a few minutes for
questions
great so we have a fantastic question
from andreas known i hope i pronounce
your name correctly if not my sincerest
apologies you are new to distributed
computing welcome to the world the
wonderful scalable world of distributed
compute you've got a great question on
andreas how does dark compare to spark
in terms of scope
performance
and ease of setup
so
i
first i just want to acknowledge that
i'm incredibly biased here i've been
working in python for over a decade
for the most part i love writing python
code and i love the pi data stack okay
if you joined a team that was already
using spark and they were very happy
with that i'd encourage you
to do so if you're starting in
distributed compute and want to figure
it out and already use pythonic tools
such as numpy
pandas or or psychic learn i i think
dusk
compares wonderfully there and in
particular you'll note that as i stated
um
um is embedded in the pi data ecosystem
in such a way that it's i mean the
people who wrote dars code were writing
pandas code and writing psychic learn
code or writing dusk in their code um so
when when you're operating in that space
i think it's
far more straightforward to get up and
running as
as quickly quickly as possible there um
and in terms of performance it's it's
incredibly incredibly
performant uh in comparison with with
spa i mean you'll see benchmarks go
each which way but there isn't um a
huge difference there for a lot of
titan for a lot of types of jobs um an
ease of setup if you're already
comfortable with the the pi data stack
um it's it's relatively easy to
to set up as well um
so i hope that that's helpful
um
fabian has a great question um fabian
enjoys the free monthly credits of
coiled um i'm so glad you you played
around with cord and you enjoy it um
which helps you play around and testing
the setup will coil keep this free
credits for the foreseeable future um
thank you for your phrasing
that question like that my understanding
is that they will keep
the free credits for the foreseeable
future i'm not sure how foreseeable that
that is but i definitely haven't caught
wind of any any plans um to not do that
and i know several people are coiled who
um
who love that they they give free
credits
um so thank you for your great question
fabian okay so i particularly i just
wanted to ask so um you just
demonstrated a
method by which we could deploy
and then you showed how
is it isn't right to upload your
credentials rights in the previous
approach so my question is
the new approach you just showed
does it solve that problem
yeah exactly so coiled is very much
making sure that all of your information
remains secure when when needed
yeah great
yeah this was a really great talk and i
personally enjoyed it
and it's it's actually this stock is
actually for people who love
experimenting
and uh thanks thank you for
being here and uh
we love
this talk